[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans ce sens public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes 90 minutes de
débat de reportage et de chronique 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts c'est
seulement demain que les premiers
convois d'aide humanitaire vont entrer
dans la bande de Gaza c'est l'urgence
absolue pour les civils palestiniens
soumis au blocus complet d'Israël depuis
l'attaque terroriste du Hamas le 7
octobre un court répit alors que
l'offensive des soldats de tsal semble
inéluctable quelle forme prendra-t-elle
quand la diplomatie pourra--elle
reprendre la main et puis la France
peut-elle jouer un rôle dans la région
on répond à toutes ces questions dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
débat c'est un zoom sur la loi
immigration que je vous propose le
gouvernement veut accélérer son adoption
persuadé que le nouveau texte aurait
permis d'éviter l'assassinat terroriste
Daras retier les titres de séjour des
étrangers en situation régulière qui
constituent une menace pour notre pays
ce sont certains des objectifs du projet
de loi immigration porté par le ministre
de l'Intérieur sur lequel nous voulons
continuer à travailler avec vous et avec
tous ceux qui veulent répondre au défis
migratoires le ministre de l'Intérieur
voulait être méchant avec les méchants
et gentil avec les gentil cet équilibre
va-t-il voler en éclat dans les
prochaines semaines l'article 3 consacré
à la régularisation des travailleurs
sans papier dans les secteurs en tension
va-t-il survivre au débat parlementaire
ne ratez pas l'analyse de nos invités
sur ce thème ce sera dans 3IS qu4s
d'heure mais d'abord le récit de cette
12e journée de guerre au Proche Orient
et la question d'un corridor humanitaire
au cœur des efforts diplomatiques Flora
sauvage des quartiers entiers rasés des
habitants sans eau ni nourriture à Gaza
au 13e jour de la guerre les portes du
point de passage de Rafa à la frontière
avec l'Égypte reste fermé les 2,4
millions de Palestiniens bloqués à Gaza
attendent toujours les camons d'aide
humanitaire promis par le président
américain et l'Égypte à des journalistes
dans l'Air Force One qui le ramenaient
de Tel Aviv Joe Biden a assuré qu'il
avait exhorté les Israéliens à soutenir
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire à
Gaza le terminal de Rafa devrait ouvrir
ses portes vendredi j'ai été très direct
sur la nécessité de soutenir
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire à
Gaza de l'acheminer à Gaza et de le
faire rapidement 2 jours après
l'explosion survenue aux abords d'un
hôpital à Gaza palestinien et Israéliens
continuent de se rejeter la
responsabilité de cette tragédie qui a
fait de nombreuses victimes civiles
avant que le président américain ne
parte pour Israël je lui ai présenté des
preuves concrètes que c'était le dihad
islamique et non l'armée israélienne qui
avait tiré le missile qui a frappé
l'hôpital à Gaza les États-Unis ont voté
contre une résolution du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU qui appelait à une
pause humanitaire entre le Hamas et
l'État hébreu depuis le début de la
guerre 400 israéliens sont morts dans
les attaques du Hamas qui détient encore
plus de 200 otages à Gaza côté
palestinien 3500 personnes sont décédés
sous les bombes israéliennes après le
président américain et le chancelier
allemand c'est le premier ministre
britannique rishiunak qui a fait le
déplacement à Jérusalem avant tout je
tiens à exprimer ma solidarité avec vous
et votre pays après avoir subi quelque
chose d'innommable nous devrions
l'appeler par son nom un acte de
terrorisme perpétré par une organisation
terroriste le Hamas une visite du
président Françis en Israël est à
l'étude mais Emmanuel Macron craint une
extension du conflit israélo-palestinien
en France alors que des manifestations
propalestiniennes se multiplient dans le
Maghreb et en Europe en France le
Conseil d'État a rappelé mercredi au
gouvernement que les manifestations en
soutien au peuple palestinien ne pouvait
être interdite systématiquement les
préfets devront évaluer le risque de
trouble à l'ordre public au cas par cas
voilà Emmanuel Macron qui demande un
délai d' descence avant ce sont ses ses
propos avant d'organiser ces
manifestations pro palestinienne en
France je vous présente tout de suite
mes invités Johann soufi bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes avocat procureur
spécialisé dans le domaine de la justice
pénale international et les droits de
l'homme et ancien chef du bureau des
affaires juridiques de l'agence de l'ONU
pour les réfugiés palestiniens Didier
laoras bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes journaliste en charge de la
géopolitique de la défense et du
terrorisme à la FP à Paris B Nabli
bonsoir bienvenue à vous professeur de
droit à lupec Paris 12 consultant
international au cabinet lisias Partners
et puis je cite votre livre relations
internationales droit théorie et
pratique qui vient de paraître aux
éditions pédon j'appelle j'accueille
pardon également Émilie zapalski bonsoir
Émilie éditorialiste pour sens public
bienvenue à vous on va démarrer il y a
plusieurs chapitres à aborder dans dans
ce débat mais je voudrais qu'on commence
par la la catastrophe humanitaire à à
Gaza c'est seulement demain que l'aide
devrait passer par Rafa donc côté
égyptien un premier témoignage cet
adolescent qui raconte le manque
d'eau
ma mère me dit de venir chercher de
l'eau nous venons et nous attendons
notre tour parfois nous attendons
pendant plus de 2hures et à la fin nous
découvrons qu'il n'y a plus d'eau je
retourne chez moi et je dis à ma mère
qu'il n'y a pas d'eau alors elle se
dispute avec moi elle me dit comment tes
frères vont-ils boire l'eau c'est la vie
aucun être humain ne peut survivre sans
eau qu'elle soit salée ou potable
personne ne peut survivre sans eau nous
remplissons deux ou trois bouteilles
juste et quand on arrive à la maison on
découvre que l'eau est salée y voilà
avec encore des incertitudes he sur
l'entrée de l'aide humanitaire demain à
l'instant euh un le patron de l'OMS de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé qui
dit il n'est pas sûr je le cite hein que
l'aide humanitaire puisse entrer dès
vendredi dans la bande de de Gaza Johan
souffi que d'écrivent vos collègues
quand on parle de catastrophe
humanitaire sur place mes collègues ils
ont plus de mots ils ont plus de mots
pour décrire la situation humanitaire
aujourd'hui c'est une situation de
terreur de terreur d'abord à cause du
conflit armé mais de terreur aussi à
cause de ce qu'on vient de voir de
l'absence d'eau de l'absence de
nourriture l'absence de médicaments on
est dans la catastrophe humanitaire la
plus absolue que l'on puisse imaginer et
et ce qui me dérange c'est que au moment
où on parle chaque jour chaque toutes
les 15 minutes selon UNICEF il y a un
enfant qui meurt et donc quand on parle
de politique et on va probablement
débattre de géopolitique et cetera moi
ce ce que je veux rappeler c'est que à
Gaza et j'ai vécu plus de 2 ans à Gaza
chaque 15 minutes un enfant meurt de des
conditions du siège total fa d'eau de
médicaments de de d'alimentation et
cetera et ceter oui mais il faut nommer
les choses euh ou des bombardements il
faut nommer les choses faute
d'intervention politique faute d'Israël
et de l'Égypte qui maintiennent ses
populations civiles privé des besoins
élémentaires à à toute vie humaine
Didier Lauras l'aide humanitaire qui va
peut-être passer demain elle suffira pas
c'estàd qu'il y a des efforts pour un
corridor humanitaire ce qui est pas la
la la même chose on en est loin
aujourd'hui diplomatiquement de ce
corridor humanitaire il y a trop il y a
trop de blocage d'après vous moi j'ai un
peu la sensation qu'il y a des blocages
de partout ou euh et et on on sait même
pas vraiment finalement si le le fond
des discussions aujourd'hui ne parle que
du corridor humanitaire on parle aussi
évidemment des otages parmi les otages
il y a des otages binationaux ou
étrangers et puis on parle évidemment
d'empêcher un embrasement total
d'empêcher le le l'entrée dans la guerre
du hzbollah donc derrière de l'Iran donc
l'explosion de la région enfin voilà
donc il y a des discussions évidemment
la diplomatie est à l'œuvre mais je suis
même pas sûr que le corridor humanitaire
soit forcément peut-être la priorité
numéro 1 mais en tout cas pas la seule h
B na cette ouverture espéré de la porte
de de Rafa est-ce qu'elle est à mettre
au crédit quand même de Joe Biden de sa
visite hier en Israël à Tel Aviv eu
alors d'abord juste rappeler que même si
la situation est exceptionnelle de ce
point de vue-là elle n'est pas
totalement nouvelle non plus pour les
Gazaoui dans la mesure où ils vivaient
déjà sous blocus oui et sous j'allais
dire sous assistance humanitaire oui
voire sous assistance respiratoire donc
c'est parce que on parle souvent d'un
avant et d'un après mais en fait il y a
aussi une forme de continuité mais mais
là plus rien ne passe oui là le qu'on un
siège total qui qui est constitutif du
point de vue du droit international d'un
crime de guerre on l'a dit on le
rappelle bon pour l'instant euh vous
avez cité la position et les efforts de
Joe Biden c'est le même Joe Biden qui
d'un côté effectivement et vous avez
raison de le rappeler a appeler plus ou
moins publiquement euh les Israéliens à
prêter l'oreille euh précisément à ses
obligations en la matière notamment en
matière de de de droit international
humanitaire et en même temps qui a voté
qui a fait
voter contre les deux résolutions qui
appelit au sein du Conseil de sécurité à
précisément répondre à cette urgence
humanitaire donc là il y a une il y a
une contradiction qui s'explique par la
ligne le fil rouge de la position
américaine dans ce conflit à savoir un
soutien inconditionnel ce qui place
mécaniquement la question humanitaire
encore aujourd'hui pour l'instant au
second plan ouie j'ai l'impression qu'il
y a quand même même si évidemment on
attend les actions humanitaire et
qu'elle puisse être possible parce que
c'est terrible la situation que vous
avez décrite et qu'on voit tous les
jours mais il semble qu'il y a quand
même un changement de ton parce que
c'est vrai que même l'offensive
terrestre d'Israël on en entend moins
parler on attendait à ce qu'elle tombe
très rapidement petit à petit on sent
quand même que il y a un peu de
relâchement de ce côté on a en effet Joe
Biden qui dit attention nous les erreurs
qu'on a fait le 11 septembre ne
reproduisaient pas on a quand même ce
changement de ton qui est probablement
obligatoire par rapport aux images qu'on
voit actuellement à tout ce débat qu' a
eu aussi sur l'hôpital à Gaza évidemment
c'est pas le c'est pas l'aboutissement
et c'est pas l'issue maintenant pour les
Gazaouis mais on sent quand même qu'il a
un flottement même si la position des
États-Unis est un peu schizophrénique en
effet Didier Loras cette offensive
terrestreilleur ser pas que terrestre
mais dont on parle depuis plusieurs
jours effectivement pourquoi elle est
retardée quelle explication on peut
donner oh il y a il y a il y a plein
d'explications d'abord je pense que
encore une fois il y avait le dossier
des otages les premiers jours c'était
quand même très compliqué après il y a
eu effectivement cette espèce de Balet
diplomatique laavenue de Joe Biden on
pouvait pas imaginer que les Israéliens
allaient lancer l'offensive juste avant
et puis après j'ai envie de dire il y a
les mots et il y a les faits il ne faut
pas oublier qu'une offensive enfin une
une guerre urbaine c'est le pire qui
puisse arriver à une armée évidemment
c'est valable aussi pour enfin c'est
valable pour les combattants de Gaza
comme pour l'armée israélienne on l'a vu
à grosen on l'a
vu plus récemment à barmmou en Ukraine
comme on l'avait vu avant à l par
exemple à Mosou en
Irak ce sont des instants absolument inv
vraisemblable de violence où la menace
vient du ré-de-chaussée des faux
plafonds des tunnels à Gaza parce qu'il
y a des tunnels à Gaza à gauche à droite
il y a des bâtiments partout il y a
absolument aucun champ de vision c'est
un enfer une guerre urbaine donc quel
que soit le la différence de de des
puissance enfin des puissances de part
et d'autre sur le papier entre Israël et
le
Hamas Israël sait qu'il a énormément à
perdre que l'issue est extrêmement
compliqué qu'il y aura énormément de
morts que évidemment tous les civils qui
seront là y compris les otages seront en
première ligne qu'au niveau des combats
dans la guerre urbaine il y a plus de
distinction entre civile et militaire et
que l'objectif d'éradiquer le Hamas il
est quoi un peu illusoire on peut dire
ça bah euh après le 11 septembre
l'Occident a décidé d'éradiquer Al-Qaïda
et on voit le résultat donc non
seulement Al-Qaïda n'est pas éradiqué
mais il y a eu depuis état islamique
donc on n'éradique pas le terrorisme on
n'éradique pas un ennemi comme ça ils
peuvent éventuellement frapper très en
profondeur
euh toutes les installations du Hamas et
ses armements ses équipements mais il va
pas éradiquer sa direction et il ne
réglera en rien la question de l'après
Hamas et la après Hamas ça rentre dans
la politique et on le sait depuis très
longtemps le le le militaire ne règle
pas la question politique Yan soufi vous
connaissez bien Gaza vous nous l'avez
dit à quel
point c'est c'est illusoire de vouloir
alors je reprends la terminologie
israélienne éradiquer le Hamas sans
faire de victime civile parce qu'il y a
effectivement ce double langage
diplomatique où on a les États-Unis mais
d'autres aussi qui disent bah oui on est
derrière vous pour nous débarrasser de
l'organisation terroriste mais ne faites
pas de victime civile à quel point c'est
impossible vous l'avez rappelé j'étais à
Gaza mais avant ça ça fait longtemps que
je travaille dans les conflits armés et
ce que j'ai noté comme vous venez de le
dire c'est que en matière de terrorisme
comme de conflit armé le militaire doit
s'accompagner d'un projet politique or
j'entends pas parler du projet politique
est-ce que c'est de réoccuper Gaza
est-ce que c'est de mettre la population
civile à nouveau sous dans des
conditions encore plus terribles
qu'elles ne le sont déjà ça est c'est un
cliché de le dire mais c'est la réalité
c'est aussi le
terreot de nouvelle peine et d'une
nouvelle violence et donc c'est un cycle
moi que je vois depuis depuis des
dizaines d'années et qui ne fait pas
améliorer la situation donc je comprends
la réaction militaire mais d'un d'un
autre côté la meilleure sécurité pour
pour Israël et pour la région et parce
que je pense aussi aux population civile
palestinienne c'est de trouver une
solution politique et humanitaire qui
est qui est
durable je tiens un
élément sur ce ce cercle ce cycle de de
violence et de haine dont vous parlez je
vous propose d'entendre la représentante
de l'Autorité palestinienne en France
elle s'appelle ala Abou Assira elle
parle de ces jeunes Palestiniens
finalement ils sont une grande majorité
à jamais avoir pu quitter la la bande de
Gaza qui n'ont donc connu que des que
des cycles de guerre
écoutonsla ce sont les enfants qui
meurent
aujourd'hui ce sont pas des diables ce
sont pas des terroristes ce sont des
enfants qui ont connu que
le siège depuis 16 ans ils ont vécu déjà
six agressions six guerres ils
connaissent que ça et ils aspirent à
leur liberté ils aspirent à à à une
dignité ils aspirent à avoir un rêve un
rêve aujourd'hui on pose la question à
un enfant palestinien il dit moi je vais
mourir cette nouvelle spirale de
violence voilà on ne se trompe pas elle
a été enclenchée le 7 octobre par la
faute du du du du Hamas il a même
certainement du cynisme de la part du
Hamas qui savait très bien qu'il y
aurait des victimes palestiniennes
civiles dans la dans la foulée mais B
nabl est-ce que c'est un piège tendu à
Israël dans lequel finalement benami
netan mais même le cabinet de guerre qui
maintenant réunit les différentes forces
politiques du pays tombe et et
peuvent-ils ne pas tomber dans ce piège
d'une certaine façon politiquement
visàis de leur opinion
publique ça peut apparaître comme un
piège mais en même temps c'est pas
vraiment nouveau on retrouve là
l'essentiel des schémas des six guerres
qui viennent d'être
c'est pratiquement le même schéma c'est
la dimension l'acuité l'intensité du
conflit qui change mais fondamentalement
des crimes perpétré aussi par oui c'est
ça auquel je pensais la dimension
l'acuité des crimes et cetera mais
fondamentalement vous avez une
provocation quelle que soit celui qui a
l'origine de cette provocation à
laquelle répond une autre enfin une
réaction de nature militaire mais
précisément le cercle vicieux dont dont
vous parlez c'est pas seulement celui de
la VI violence c'est l'absence du
politique il est là en fait je pense le
cercle vicieux à aucun moment une
perspective politique n'apparaît et
lorsqu'on parle ou lorsqu'on évoque les
les six guerres entre-etemps qu'est-ce
qu'il y a en fait il y a un vide
politique et une situation de blocus
donc vous voyez bien que l'équation elle
est il faut à un moment donné prendre un
peu de de hauteur et de recul et se dire
mais en fait une fois que cette séquence
là va se terminer on va revenir à une
forme de normalité et à quoi correspond
cette normalité une population qui vit
dans une prison à ciel ouvert vous voyez
bien qu'on en sort pas et si on n sort
pas c'est parce que on raisonne trop en
terme militaire alors que le problème
est de nature politique mais mais did
Loras des deux côtés que ce soit côté
israélien ou côté palestinien
aujourd'hui c'est c'est quand même les
extrémistes qui ont qui qui ont la main
alors peut-être un peu moins côté
israélien parce qu'il y a un cabinet de
guerre ou une union une sorte d'union
nationale mais est-ce qu'on peut est-ce
que vous dites ça alors déjà
je on pourrait on pourrait dire ça je
voudrais pas
confondre le discours extrême de
Benjamin netanahou et les actions qui
ont été perpétré par le Hamas le 7
octobre on parle quand même pas
exactement de la même chose ou on est
d'accord pour autant euh je pense que ça
vient d'être dit très clairement enfin
il a il y a eu six guerres et et
finalement entre ces
guerres à chaque fois le ton s'est durci
et et la et la normalité devient une
polarisation extrême une radicalisation
des deux côté une situation dans
lequelle effectivement le politique au
sens gestion de la cité trouver une
solution a complètement disparu une
solution à deux états
aujourd'hui on parlait tout à l'heure de
diplomatie je pense qu'il y a pas un
diplomate qui a prononcé ce mot depuis
des mois en tout cas depuis 10 jours
c'est sûr donc la diplomatie aujourd'hui
elle en est réduite à essayer de faire
du du de la gestion des dégâts on on
n'est pas sur l'après ouais mais mais on
y sera sur l'après Johan souopi il y a
bien un moment où finalement cette
horreur que l'on est en train de vivre
ce temps de guerre va devrait déboucher
sur autre chose que ce soit il a il y
aura forcément une initiative
internationale enfin on peut l'espérer
peut-être que c'est mon côté optimiste
qui s'exprime là moi aussi je suis
optimiste généralement et je me dis que
je sais plus qui disait ça d'ailleurs
que la folie c'est de faire
systématiquement la même chose et
d'espérer un résultat différent on on a
on a essayé la violence est de chaque
côté on s'est dit plus de violence et ça
va changer la situation et on arrive
dans des situations de blocage qu'on
donc bien évidemment que je suis
optimiste parce que aussi je travaille
dans le domaine de la justice pénale
internationale et des choses qu'on
pensait impensables impensable j'étais
encore en Ukraine il y a quelques mois
au moment où on a mis en accusation
Vladimir Poutine pour des crimes de
guerre aujourd'hui je pense et et je
prêche un peu pour cela c'est je pense
que viendra le temps à la fois de la
diplomatie et de la justice pénale
internation mais c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé moi de tous mes vœux à ce que
l'ONU les instruments du
multilatéralisme mais également la Cour
pénale internationale s'intéresse à la
situation en Palestine ouis l'ONU par la
voix de Isral par la voix de son
secrétaire général Antonio guterz qui
appelle c'était en cette fin
d'après-midi un cesser le feu
humanitaire à Gaza ça semble là aussi
totalement
illusoirenabl et on se demande ce que
pèse encore la voix de du Secrétaire
général de l'ONU pardon de dire ça oui
bon c'est pas vraiment nous
non parce que fait longtemps que dans
l'avion de la gouvernance mondiale il y
a plus de pilote non surtout que dans
enfin parmi les organes onusiens celui
qui compte le plus c'est le Conseil de
sécurité c'est à Lui qui revient la
responsabilité finalement décisionnelle
ou décisionnaire or il est
neutralisé voilà il est bloqué par un
jeu de puissance assez classique d'une
certaine manière il nous renvoie à la
guerre froide là la la distribution des
puissances n'est pas la même mais le
résultat est le même c'est
neutralisation des uns des autres
résultat les de deux projets de
résolution qui qui ont été soumis au
vote pour précisément et notamment soit
obtenir un cesser le feu soit permettre
l'assistance humanitaire ont été ont été
neutralisé donc voyez bien comment ce
jeu de puissance ne permet pas aussi euh
de dessiner l'après et puis par ailleurs
si l'ONU est bloqué c'est parce que plus
largement cette séquence fait écho à la
reconfiguration de l'ordre international
et ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
il y a une résonance très forte avec la
guerre en Ukraine alors soit je je
j'essaie de prendre la balle au bond que
que permet mon mon camarade dans la
mesure où il a parlé de la Cour pénale
internationale et l'un des faits
prignants saisissants dans la guerre en
Ukraine c'est la manière la dextérité
avec laquelle la cour à travers son
procureur a réagi c'était très important
symboliquement politiquement et
juridiquement qu'il aille mener des
enquêtes soutenues par les États-membres
de la Cour pénale pour essayer d'établir
les fait et de faire la démonstration
des crimes de guerre russes sur le
territoire ukrainien et malheureusement
il y a un contraste saisissant avec la
passivité le silence des mêmes instances
de la Cour pénale internationale
notamment que que je soutiens moi en
tant qu'instance j'y crois il faut
qu'elle
fonctionne et ce contraste là
malheureusement tout le monde le
constate et nourrit précisément à la
fois euh la défiance du Sud global
vis-à-vis des des discours occidentaux
Ham soit la Russie dans le conflit face
à l'Ukraine soit Israël après les crimes
qui ont été perpétrés contre ces civils
et plus largement ça nourrit alors je
dirais même c'est pire hein la position
russe et chinoise qui consiste à dire
écoutez l'ordre international tel qu'il
existe il est le produit des puissances
de l'après Seconde Guerre mondiale il
fonctionneent lorsque leurs intérêt
fonctionneent lorsque leurs intérêts ne
correspondent pas au mécanisme prévu et
bien tout est bloqué c'est ce à on on
assiste et malheureusement tout cela
infin vous parlez de de l' près j'ai
bien peur que la Russie notamment sorte
renforcé de la séquence un autre
témoignage dans notre débat celui d'un
survivant israélien de l'attaque du du
du 7 octobre il s'appelle a pterman il
est avec deux autres survivants il était
au Parlement européen hier pour plaider
auprès de de l'Union un soutien Israël
dans son Comat contre le Hamas et pour
la libération des otages on l'écoute
il faut s'occuper du Hamas il faut
s'occuper du Hamas pour que nous ayons
une vie décente mais aussi pour que les
Palestiniens aent une vie
décente on va ouvrir un chapitre
consacré justement au au palestiniens au
soutien des Palestiniens vis-àvis du
Hamas et puis au soutien des
Palestiniens dans les pays arabes c'est
un chapitre assez vaste Didier Loras
d'abord le le le le Hamas et le peuple
palestinien qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire
il y a eu des élections mais très
lointaine depuis
euh écoutez très honnêtement je ne sais
pas vous répondre peut-être que certains
de des personnes sur le plateau
pourraient vous l'avez dit vous-même euh
l'élection est très lointaine qu'est-ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la tête
des Palestiniens qui constatent le
résultat de ce qui vient de se passer
est-ce que on peut objectivement
imaginer que cet adolescent qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui va chercher de l'eau
et qui revient avec 2 l d'eau salée donc
qui a été en gros prise dans la mer qui
donc qui qui sa mère qui le l'engueule
passez-moi l'expression parce qu'il a il
a pas ramener d'eau est-ce que cette
famille là se dit oui mais quand même ça
valait le coup parce que franchement le
coup de Hamas c'était c'était bien enfin
voilà donc aujourd'hui la question de
l'opinion publique de la bande de Gaza
parce que si on va en syjordanie c'est
potentiellement encore autre chose parce
que comme vousfin voilà tout ça
extrêmement
compliqué je moi je n'ai rien lu de
cohérent et de solide depuis 10 jours
sur quelle est l'opinion réelle des des
habitants de la B de Gaza vis-à-vis du
Hamas qui les dirige ouaisen soufi
est-ce possible de répondre à ma
question non parce que premièrement la
communauté enfin la population civile à
Gaza c'est pas un monolite donc elle est
elle est elle est diverse elle est et
elle est aussi changeante bien
évidemment quand quand c'est au
lendemain d'un bombardement israélien et
bien il y a plus peut-être de soutien
avec un mouvement qui là-bas est
considéré comme le seul mouvement de
résistance à à au blocus quand il y a
des crimes comme ceuxl bien évidemment
qui sont largement rejetés par la
population civile mais mais voilà donc
c'est mais ils ont aucune occasion de
s'exprimer démocratiquement il faut
aussi dire ça non parce que voilà parce
que il y a pas de liberté d'expression à
Gaza et parce que aussi le sentiment qui
prévaut et vous l'avez très bien dit à
la fois à Gaza mais dans le sud global
c'est c'est le mot injustice et et donc
injustice de partout injustice d'être
pris en otage entre x entre un
gouvernement israélien extrémiste et et
un mouvement extrémiste comme le Hamas
donc bien évidemment la la population
civile là-bas ne sait pas quoi penser ne
sait pas à qui à qui se FIA votre avis
là-dessus naab je pense que forcément
oui le sentiment doit être ambivalent
vous avez peut-être dans un premier
temps un sentiment d'orgueil dans un
dans une situation de enfin un sentiment
d'humiliation qui habite beaucoup de
Palestiniens en se disant on aorta un
coup historique et puis un deuxième
temps plus lucide on on apprécie le coût
de ce coup h et là pour le le cou
c'estut exactement vous m'avez compris
et et et on a affaire à à des à des gens
aussi qui ont qui ont une part de de
naturellement de lucidité et qui ne vont
pas cautionner euh cette entreprise et
je pense que la vraie question qu'on
pourrait se poser nous c'est si on
organisit un un référendum euh soumis
aux Palestiniens avec la question de
savoir finalement est-ce que vous êtes
pour la vision l'option l'offre
politique du Hamas ou celle d'une
partition du territoire en question avec
à la clé un État palestinien et
abandonner bah le rêve de d'une grande
Palestine de 40
48 là on verrait que le Hamas serait
minoritaire largement minoritaire voyez
parce que si on reprend la charte du
Hamas qui nie l'existence d'Israël euh
et veut détruire l'État hébreux et oui
donc une manière de de de nier à la fois
son existence et sa possibilé son avenir
quoi dans la région euh les Palestiniens
ne soutiennent pas à priori cette
perspective làà cette position là donc
c'est je pense que c'est la question et
d'où l'intérêt de remettre sur la table
la question d'un d'un avenir étatique un
cadre étatique pour cette population
palestinienne après la la la frappe
contre l'hôpital contre l'hôit it al de
de Gaza l'opinion publique est quand
même en en ébullition dans plusieurs
pays arabes on va voir des images
d'Istanbul d'abord manifestation hier
soir c'était devant le
consulat d'Israël on va aussi découvrir
des des images de la capitale
jordanienne d'amam d'Aman pardon ou
alors de Casablanca au Maroc là la
manifestation avait lieu près du
consulat américain voilà on va voir
défiler ces ces différentes images euh
je reste avec vous BBL parce que
aujourd'hui le président égyptien al c
le roi Abdallah georgani réclame l'arrêt
immédiat du conflit les mêmes qui
devaient participer à un som un sommet
quadripartite avec avec Joe Biden et
Mahmoud Abbas donc on va parler dans
dans un instant ils doivent quoi donner
desgages à leur opinion publique est-ce
qu'on peut dire ça aujourd'hui oui c'est
ça en fait ils sont pris en tenail entre
d'un côté leur alliance stratégique avec
les États-Unis et la normalisation
qu'ils ont acté depuis pas mal de temps
avec Israël donc des des engagements
internationaux très fort qui qui définit
leur identité internationale et de
l'autre une population une société
civile qui est vivante qui est active
alors même que les régimes en question
ne sont pas démocratiques c'est une
c'est une belle contradiction parce que
souvent on assimile dictature ou régime
autoritaire à finalement une
neutralisation absolue de de la société
civile
là cette idée là de normalisation entre
certains régimes arabes et et Israël
illustre parfaitement bah la fiction de
cette de de cette de cette fiction
suivant laquelle il n'y aurait pas de
vie publique voire démocratique d'une
certaine manière dans les régimes même
autoritaires voyez même le Maroc qui a
été l'un des derniers
signataires de ce processus de
normalisation le roi dont l'autorité
n'est pas contestée fait quand même face
à une à une société civile qui s'est
exprimée fortement et lui-même est
appelé à prendre en considération cette
réalité sociale et politique à savoir
l'ancrage dans l'imaginaire des
populations arabes de la cause
palestinienne tout simplement alors il y
avait aussi des milliers de Palestiniens
dans dans les rues qui ont manifesté
hier et les jours précédents en 6
Jordanie occupé on va parler tout de
suite avec Marion delpèche qui peut me
rejoindre sur ce plateau bonsoir Marion
bienvenue à vous des rassemblements en
au cours duquel le le soutien au
mouvement islamiste ramas semble on va
être prudent s'être renforcé au
détriment du président l'Autorité
palestinienne Mahmoud Abbas et oui tout
à fait he Thomas des manifestations qui
se sont tenues dans plusieurs villes de
6 jordaniens occupé par Israël depuis
1967 à Hébron hein comme on va le voir
sur sur ces images mais aussi à
naplelouse ou encore à ramala où s'est
également tenu une journée de grève
générale ces rassemblements et bien ils
étaient organisés suite à la frappe qui
a touché un hôpital de Gaza et donct
israélien et Palestiniens s'accusent
mutuellement et plus largement et bien
en opposition au bombardement d'Israël
sur la bande de Gaza et alors là où on
en vient au cœur de votre chronique
c'est que dans la foule certains
manifestants critiquaient le président
de l'Autorité palestinienne oui tout à
fait au-delà d'appeler à la libération
de la Palestine de nombreus slogan ont
été scandés comme Abas Abbas tournant en
dérision le plus vieux dirigeant du
monde arabe Marmoud Abbas pivot des
accords d'Oslo de 93 qui visaient à
résoudre le conflit israëlpalestine il
est âgé de 87 ans il est au pouvoir
depuis 2005 parfois surnommé Abou Mazen
son nom de chef de guerre c'est à ramala
qu'il siège à la tête de l'Autorité
palestinienne et c'est là et bien que
des affrontements ont éclaté hier avec
de jeunes palestiniens qui ont lancé des
pierres en direction des soldats
israéliens ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à brandir les insignes du Hamas
au pouvoir dans la bande de Gaza et à
antoné deschanoutenant le mouvement
islamiste auquel marmou Abbas et lui
toujours opposé sans jamais réussir à le
fragiliser le président Abbas a
d'ailleurs estimé dimanche dernier que
les politiques et les actions du Hamas
ne représentent pas le peuple
palestinien que reprochent ces
manifestants au au présent de l'autorité
palestinenne et bien il lui reproche
d'être trop faible en face aux
Occidentaux et face à Israël certains
appellent à sa destitution et demande la
fin de la coopération sécuritaire avec
Israël on a posé la question à Damien
Simono chercheur et expert en politique
de sécurité frontal frontalière on
l'écoute l'Autorité palestinienne est
perçue comme corrompue comme trop
autoritaire il y a eu des manifestations
dans la foulée des printemps arables
contre marmodabas déjà et là dans la
situation présente
marboabas incarne une trop grosse
compromission aux yeux de nombreux
Palestiniens avec Israël notamment via
les accords de sécurité qui lie
israélien et palestinien de l'autorité
palestinienne donc c'est pour ça que le
Hamas apparaît aujourd'hui pour beaucoup
de Palestiniens comme le seul à même de
proposer une forme de résistance armée
même si ça va jusqu'à des massacres de
civil israélien c'est le seul et c'est
ce qu'on entend bien évidemment dans euh
beaucoup de manifestations
aujourd'hui alors après l'attaque
sanglante menée par ses commandos le 7
octobre le Hamas a en fait accéléré la
marginalisation de l'Autorité
palestinienne et de son président de
Abbas qui s'accroche ces dernières
années au pouvoir malgré l'absence
d'État ou de contrôle sur son territoire
occupé par l'armée israélienne
aujourd'hui cependant il est difficile
d'évaluer le poids du parti islamiste
chez les Palestiniens et là je vais
pouvoir répondre à une interrogation que
vous posiez tout à l'heure car il n'y a
pas eu d'élection nationale et bien
depuis 18 ans merci beaucoup Marion pour
ces informations Didier Loras est-ce que
le simple fait de de d'avoir été
potentiellement invité au sommet
quadripartite c'est c'est pas aussi une
façon une forme de discrédit pour mmoud
Abbas auprès d'une partie de la rue
palestinienne fait d'être adoubé
finalement comme un interlocuteur
potentiel de de
l'Occident je j'aurais du mal à j'aurais
du mal à répondre à la question parce
que j'ai du mal à percevoir à quel point
la rue palestinienne comment comme vous
l'appelez est sensible à ces jeux
géopolitiques là je pense que l'image de
mmoud Abbas elle est aussi très affaibli
depuis très longtemps euh
pourquoi parce que parce que la gestion
euh par l'Autorité palestinienne est
corrompue parce que elle est inefficace
parce que c'est un personnage qui n'a
plus le charisme qu'il a eu parce que
parce que on le disait tout à l'heure il
est il est il est arrivé au pouvoir avec
des ambitions extrêmement fortes et
aujourd'hui il quittera le pouvoir
vivant ou mort en ayant échoué donc je
pense que ça figure aujourd'hui euh de
toute façon elle elle ne pèse plus
grand-chose je suis pas sûr que la
question de sa participation ou pas à
une telle discussion soit soit majeure
mais peut-être que vous avez je trouve
que c'est quand même très intéressant ce
qui se passe parce qu'on voit la
population quand même quelque part se
réveiller et probablement ce que vous
avez dit depuis le début c'est qu'il y a
pas de perspective politique et on sent
bien que cette population qui est
assiégée qui souffre énormément c'est
Palestiniens qui voient tout ça ils ont
conscience comme nous qu'il y a pas de
perspective politique ils sont pas B il
le voit bien et quelque part on a
l'impression que c'est des temps
nouveaux où peut-être les populations
peuvent agir davantage je prendrai en
exemple en miroir un peu ce que Zelenski
a fait avec sa population on y croyait
pas du tout on pensait que la Russie
allait arriver en un mois il a réveillé
sa population il a réussi à faire une
espèce de résistance auquel on ne
croyait pas donc peut-être qu'on est
passé à une époque un peu différente où
on peut se dire que évidemment dans un
cadre très contraint puisque on n'est
pas du tout dans les mêmes systèmes
politiques mais on sent bien qu'il y a
quelque chose qui n'est ni une confiance
absolue dans le Hamas ou dans le
l'Autorité palestinienne ni une
confiance évidemment absolu à ce qui se
passe au niveau international puisque
ils sont conscients comme nous qu'il se
passe rien du tout sur le plan politique
et que ça fait six guerres et beaucoup
d'années qui sont dans ce dans ce
marasme et qui voi bien que rien ne se
passe et je je reprends par rapport aux
jeunes qui n'ont pas d'avenir on voit
bien c'est des c'est quand même des
population comme le disait tout à
l'heure la représentante Palestine qui
ont pas d'avenir quoi c'est des jeunes
qui ont zéro avenir quand même euh faut
quand même rappeler que Abbas lorsqu'il
arrive à la présidence de l'Autorité
palestinienne c'est salué par la
communauté internationale monoccidentale
en particulier et par Israël et il fait
un choix politique très clair considère
que la violence c'est une impasse et
donc il s'oppose frontalement au Hamas
et il considère que le destin des
Palestiniens passe par une stratégie
diplomatique qui va se traduire par une
offensive à l'ONU puisque les
Palestiniens vont demander un un statut
d'état-membre et une offensive vers la
Cour pénale internationale même chose
avec une demande de statut d'état-membre
il a échoué non seulement il il avait
raison on a tous dit une solution
politique éch violence n'était pas il a
échoué mais il ne voulait pas échouer il
y avait une volonté politique de son
côté et cette volonté n'a été soutenue
ni par les Occidentaux h lors des
différents votes soit l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies ou plutôt au
Conseil de sécurité par pardon soit euh
au niveau de la Cour pénale
internationale ni par les dirigeants
israéliens qui en fait n'ont pas joué le
jeu autrement dit n'ont pas saisi la
main tendue par ce président de
l'Autorité palestinienne qui venait
succéder à Arafat qui était auis par les
dirigeants palestiniens don Israëliens
donc là l'impasse vous voyez à un moment
donné renvoie la question de la
responsabilité politique des uns et des
autres allez il nous reste quelques
minutes et je voudrais qu'on parle
encore de diplomatie notamment de
diplomatie française avec d'abord euh un
des éléments d'actualité de cette
journée la visite du Premier ministre
britannique en Israël Richi sunac
écoutons le le président israélien qui
qui l'accueille Isac
Herzog il s'agit d'un test le moment est
venu de savoir qui est notre ami qui est
avec nous et vous avez été avec nous dès
le premier instant et nous vous sommes
extrêmement reconnaissants Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pour votre soutien et
vos décisions et votre leadership à cet
égard et nous vous accueillons les bras
en raison de ce
moment Richi sunak en israëlapski
Emmanuel Macron doit-il y aller il va il
va pas pour le moment Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas complètement décidé ou plutôt
il a décidé d'attendre il faut dire que
la situation évidemment très compliqué
en France où les clivages sont très
importants les prises de position des
uns et des autres très radicales alors
je vous passe tous les échange sur la
nuupess Jean-Luc Mélenchon des
célébrités aussi ici ou là qui prennent
position et sur place bien sûr on en a
parlé c'est aussi très compliqué les
déplacements de certains responsables
politiques Joe Biden en l'occurrence ont
été très mouvementés le président
américain est arrivé sur le sol
israélien au même moment que l'explosion
d'un hôpital à Gaza il a dû par la suite
annuler la seconde partie de son voyage
prévu en Jordanie mais au moins il y
était tout comme le chanelier allemand
et puis le Premier ministre britannique
dont on vient de parler côté français on
s'en tient pour l'instant à la ministre
des Affaires étrangères Catherine colon
elle était sur place il y a 4 jours et à
une délégation qui était aussi là-bas il
y a 4 jours de députés Renaissance et
les républicains pourant l'opposition
aimerait bien une présence un petit peu
plus appuyée à l'image de Bruno
retaillot qui hier avoué sur Radio J
qu'il aurait aimé qu'Emmanuel Macron y
aille en premier comment expliquez-vous
ces hésitations alors bien sûr il y a
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard c'est
c'est pas pour rien Emmanuel Macron se
devait d'être présent aux obsèques du
professeur Daras ça se déroule rouler
aujourd'hui on est aussi en alerte
urgence attentat donc il s'agit de
rassurer sa population mais dans la tête
de notre Président il y a autre chose il
y a surtout l'idée de ne faire le
déplacement au Proche Orient que s'il y
a quelque chose à annoncer et il l'a dit
lui-même lors d'une conférence de presse
qui avait lieu en Albanie avant-hier le
17 octobre il dit ma volonté c'est de
pouvoir me déplacer lorsque nous pouvons
obtenir un accord concret soit sur la
nonescalade soit sur les questions
humanitaires donc il faut quelque part
ce qu'il appelle un agenda utile
pourtant dans le cadre du conflit en
Ukraine l'homme n'a pas hésité à se
rendre sur place ni à mettre en scène
ces négociations quand bien même elles
ont échoué on se souvient des des films
qui étaient tournés sur ces discussions
avec Poutine lesélusé l'assure cela dit
il continue à négocier avec les
dirigeants du Proche Orient et pour nous
il s'est exprimé sur le sujet le 12
octobre à 20h appelant à l'unité alors
cette ces hésitations plutôt bonne ou
mauvaise nouvelle alors finalement on
peut peut-être sen réjouir puisque ces
hésitations elles dessinent un président
peut-être un petit peu plus prudent que
d'habitude dans ses relations à
l'international mais est-ce que cette
position est tenable longtemps au-delà
de la situation politique il y a aussi
les otages he SEP français sont toujours
portés disparu et donc probablement
otage du Hamas marquer la solidarité
envers les familles ça serait peut-être
important finalement on a un peu
l'impression du côté de la France que le
film défile sous nos yeux sans qu'on y
trouve aucun rôle même secondaire oui et
à l'instant Emmanuel Macron qui a dit
craindre la division en France si la
situation est mal gérée c'est peut-être
là l'explication bernablis d'abord des
des raisons de politique française qui
qui expliquent le l'absence pour
l'instant du président en Israël alors
le rapport entre la France et le conflit
israëlo-palestinien s'inscrit dans une
histoire longue dans la mesure où nos
présidents qui sont responsables de la
politique étrangère se sont
traditionnellement engagés sur sur ce
dossier avec une ligne assez claire à
l'époque du président du général de
Gaulle jusqu'au président Chirac il y a
une continuité qu'on résume par la
formule de bien connue la ligne
politique
golomiterandienne qui est assez simple à
comprendre c'est celle qui consiste à
renvoyer au respect du droit
international et à la perspective d'une
solution à deux états or on on s'en est
éloigné euh je pense oui je pense qu'on
s'est éloigné de de cette ligne là de
cet équilibre là depuis la présidence
Sarkozy et surtout depuis la présidence
Hollande qui connaît aujourd'hui une
consécration une formalisation je dirais
à travers la présidence Macron que je
résumerai en quelques mots une mise en
retrait par rapport à ce dossier parce
que précisément il n'y a pas grand-chose
à gagner il y a très très peu de Levi ou
de marge d'action pour les pour la
France sur ce dossier-là et puis
deuxièmement comme vous l'avez dit une
dimension ion interne parce que à côté
de ce de cette formule lancinante à
l'égard du risque d'importation du
conflit qui est assez hypocrite je pense
en fait c'est une question aussi d'ordre
interne pas le conflit en tant que tel
mais la question le dossier
elle affecte notre vie publique voir
certains foyers privés et forcément pour
un chef d'État qui est aussi un homme
politique sous la 5e République il est
pas simplement au-dessus du débat et
bien il est obligé de prendre en
considération les risques encus par une
position qui serait soit trop
déséquilibré soit euh qui serait mal
interprété et donc il y a une forme de
prudence qui se traduit notamment par
une forme d'ineaction alors juste un
élément objectif lorsque je dis qu'il y
a une forme de rupture par rapport à la
ligne
glomiterandienne la France n'a pas
appelé dans les premiers temps à cesser
le feu il y a un long silence qui rond
avec notre tradition qui consistait
notamment dans ce type de configuration
conflictuelle à appeler un cesser le feu
et à une solution au moins humanitaire
dans un premier temps et eu silence par
contraste merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de votre livre relation
internationales droit théorie et
pratique publié aux éditions pédon à
bientôt sur le plateau de Public Sénat